organic farmer Mariano Jimenez
cultivates corn in the Oregon region of
Spain
unlike other local corn growers he
doesn't use pesticides nor does he plant
genetically modified corn seed 17 years
ago I switched from conventional to
organic farming I wanted to produce
healthier crops that didn't damage the
environment that's why I formed this way
still the farmer has a problem
genetically modified corn is grown on
25% of corn fields in Spain GM corn is
more resistant to pests but it
contaminates organic corn production
that has economic consequences for
organic farmers it eats into their
profits no no no bull when they're
coming once the corn is contaminated I
can't sell it as organic produce even if
there are trace amounts of GM
contamination in my harvest it means I
have to sell my crops as conventional
corn Spanish agronomist Rosa bean
emily's is an expert on the issue
she's examined the interaction between
the different strains one way they
interact us through pollination pollen
from the GM corn carried on the wind or
by insects inseminates the organic corn
that means that the cross pollinated
kernels will carry traces of DNA from
the GM cone element of stress chemicals
Spain has been allowing the use of GM
corn for 18 years in other European
countries genetically modified crops are
officially banned dahveed suns as a
fervent advocate of GM corn even though
it's more expensive he notes that
insects such as caterpillars can no
longer destroy the plants because the
modified strain produces a protein
that's toxic to pests we can't afford to
lose 30 percent of the harvest because
the corn we grow is riddled with
caterpillars cultivating corn is already
expensive that's why we've turned to GM
corn it ensures that we'll have a
perfect harvest
Roza beanie malice is critical of the GM
corn she points to its high cost because
agribusiness holds patents on the
genetically modified seeds when we talk
about GM plants we have to address the
agricultural model and the monopolies
penny goes hey guys I see I'm drownin
españa so I'm known as GM seed is
produced by just a handful of companies
who control the market el mercado muy
fuerte men take on central office -
Mariano Jimenez has considered whether
it would be better not to grow organic
corn any more because of the high
probability of contamination from GM
strains
instead he would grow organic vegetables
traditional agriculture is disappearing
we used to grow corn now it's all about
GM corn so we can't grow normal corn
that hasn't been manipulated and in the
EU it's illegal to sell that for human
consumption GM corn can only be fed to
animals there